[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue qui va
diriger notre région bientôt nous
vendons dans 3 jours exactement dimanche
alors la gauche va-t-elle réussir à
conserver sa majorité le rassemblement
national et les républicains peuvent-ils
encore croire à la victoire et la
majorité présidentielle va-t-elle jouer
les troubles fêtes c'est l'heure du
grand débat de cette entre deux tours et
ses sur France 3 une émission en
collaboration avec France Bleu tout à
l'heure Stéphane Paris sera avec nous
pour l'ayez vos questions et puis bien
sûr à mes côtés ce soir Jérémy chevreuil
bonsoir Jérémy bonsoir Elsa bonsoir à
tous je suis ravi de vous retrouver ici
sur la scène du Palais des Congrès de
Beaune avec nos invités nous sommes en
direct jusqu'à 19h ils étaient 7 au
premier tour ils ne sont plus que 4 ce
soir quatre prétendants à la présidence
du conseil régional de Bourgogne
Franche-Comté je vous les présente tout
de suite marie-kid du fait du Parti
socialiste votre liste s'intitule notre
région Parker vous êtes arrivés en tête
du premier tour avec 26 et demi pour
cent des suffrages Julien redoule du
rassemblement national à la tête de la
liste pour une région qui nous protège
vous êtes deuxième de ce premier tour
avec 23,2 %. j'ai le plâtré candidat les
républicains vous menez la liste pour la
Bourgogne et la Franche-Comté qui a
obtenu 21 % au premier tour et enfin
Denis turio la République en marche à la
tête de la liste de la région partout et
pour tous liste qui a obtenu 11,7% des
voix dimanche dernier bonsoir à tous les
quatre merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation pour cette ultime débat à
trois jours donc du deuxième tour
décisif je précise que votre placement
sur scène a été tiré au sort et puis
pour vous qui nous regardez à la
télévision ou sur le site Internet de
France 3 Bourgogne Franche-Comté vous
pouvez commenter ce débat sur les
réseaux sociaux avec le mot dièse regfc
comme régional Bourgogne Franche-Comté
et pour commencer nous avons demandé à
chacun d'entre vous d'apporter une photo
qui lui tient à cœur une photo qui
symbolise la Bourgogne Franche-Comté et
on va commencer avec vous Gilles plâtré
on va découvrir votre photo je vous
laisse nous la présenter oui c'est un
souvenir qui m'est cher c'est un paysan
qui était né à la fin du 19e siècle et
qui a donné sa vie pour son pays en
octobre 1914 comme beaucoup de paysans
Bourguignons et franc-comtoir il avait
été placé avec son régiment pour essayer
de contrer l'avance allemande dans la
Meuse ce qu'on appelait le Saillon de
Saint-Mihiel et c'est un homme qui
compte beaucoup pour moi puisque c'est
mon arrière-grand-père et son souvenir
que j'ai plaisir à évoquer devant vous à
sans doute un peu contribué aussi à mon
engagement et puis surtout cette
admiration sans bande que j'ai pour
celles et ceux qui se battent pour leur
patrie
merci Gilles plâtré Julien ou double
quel est votre photo et pourquoi l'avoir
choisi c'est Madame Simone audoul
beccardi c'est ma grand-mère c'est si je
puis dire la femme de ma vie c'est celle
qui a permis que je sois élu c'est elle
qui m'a orienté vers ma formation
d'historien c'est elle qui m'a donné
aussi envie de m'engager pour mon
département de l'Yonne c'est mes
premiers liens avec la Bourgogne c'est
elle qui m'a fait découvrir les
escargots la gougère c'est elle qui m'a
fait visiter notre patrimoine je lui
dois énormément et elle m'accompagne en
chaque instant elle n'est plus de ce
monde malheureusement depuis trois ans
et j'ai pensé à elle tout au long de
cette campagne c'est pour elle aussi et
pour tous nos anciens tous ceux qui
finalement ont porté je dirais nos
territoires tous ceux qui ont contribué
à façonner être région que je me bats et
que j'ai envie de protéger celles et
ceux qui constituent la Bourgogne
Franche-Comté merci Julien audoul Denis
Thuriot quel est votre photo et pourquoi
cette photo
écoutez puisque nous sommes en famille
alors c'est pas ma mère mais c'est une
photo de ma mère qui est photographe
comme l'été mes grands-parents c'est
surtout une photo du lac de Chaumont qui
est dans le parc régional du Morvan et
pour moi ça symbolise beaucoup de choses
qui peuvent être rattachées à la région
évidemment l'eau dont je souhaite faire
une grande cause régionale parce que
c'est un enjeu l'eau de l'hiver doit
être l'eau de demain c'est l'eau qui
protège puisque c'est un retenu qui
protège notamment Paris des inondations
et puis vous apercevez aussi une forte
zone boisée et c'est l'économie une
partie de l'économie de la bourré de
Franche-Comté la sylviculture en mettant
la biodiversité depuis quelque part une
des raisons qui attire en bourré une
Franche-Comté le tourisme puis dernière
argument c'est une belle photo comme les
notre belle région Bruay Franche-Comté
je trouvais que ça allait bien j'aurais
pu choisir le lac des Rousses le lacs du
poing dans le Doubs c'est pas les lacs
qui manquent mais en tout cas celui-là
est important merci Denis Turu et enfin
Marie guide du fait quel est votre photo
et pourquoi ce choix
alors cette photo c'est la photo d'une
boulangerie qui a
René je sais pas si c'est comme ça
boulangerie qui n'existait plus dans ce
petit village tout petit village de
l'Yonne à Paris et donc vous voyez cette
boulangerie s'intitule parlez-moi
d'amour
cette boulangerie elle a ressuscité
parce que dans ce village où il n'y
avait plus aucun commerce des habitants
et surtout des nouveaux habitants venus
de l'extérieur de cette région ont eu
envie de s’entrer dans ce village et de
développer une vraie vie de village et
donc on fait renaître cette boulangerie
en allant chercher d'ailleurs un
excellent boulanger et la région les a
appuyés et c'est donc l'illustration de
cette ruralité conquérante d'être
ruralité innovantes au moment où on
parle beaucoup de la ruralité abandonnée
quand une boulangerie renaît c'est tout
un village qui renaît derrière ce sont
des associations ce sont des animations
le dimanche qui s'organisent autour du
fournil et donc c'est un symbole de de
vie en milieu rural qui met très très
cher Parly parlez-moi d'amour merci on
parlera de la ruralité tout au long de
cette émission mais d'abord je vous
propose de revenir sur le premier tour
de ces élections dimanche dernier avec
un phénomène un fait très marquant
l'abstention deux électeurs sur trois ne
sont pas allés voter on va écouter
justement ces franc-comtois et ses
Bourguignons des abusé qui ont boudé les
urnes on les écoute et après on en
discute tous ensemble
non j'ai pas voté parce que ça
m'intéresse pas ça m'intéresse pas
j'ai pas eu le temps de m'en occuper
vraiment
ça n'a aucun impact réel pour moi ça n'a
aucun intérêt
je ne savais pas je n'avais pas le temps
ça n'a pas d'intérêt pas d'impact sur ma
vie quotidienne Denis turio que
répondez-vous à ces abstentionnistes à
ses citoyens qui se sont détournés des
urnes dimanche dernier et en même temps
que c'est injuste parce que les élus je
pense font de leur mieux quel que soit
leur bord d'ailleurs et que la région
est très présente dans le quotidien des
Bourguignons francontois je pense que
c'est la révélation aussi d'un échec
d'avoir transmis quelle était cette
région justement dans les transports
dans l'aide à l'économie dans l'aide aux
entreprises qui parfois emploi ce qui
s'abstiennent donc il y a manifestement
une inadéquation entre ce que fait la
région chaque jour parce qu'elle n'est
pas connue et je le dis dans mon
programme moi je souhaiterais que mes
élus régionaux soient présents sur leur
terrain aux côtés des mers aux côtés des
présentes communautés de communes aux
côtés des entreprises et qu'on connaisse
leur nom à la fin du mandat parce que
c'est un pari que je vous fais refaites
le même reportage vous verrez personne
ne sera capable de citer le non-sokosi
régional c'est une réalité et donc c'est
surtout voilà dommage parce que
l'abstention quelque part c'est notre
première adversaire aux uns et aux
autres et l'abstention n'est sûrement
pas la solution donc il faut tout faire
pour motiver les gens aller voter je
rappelle que voter c'est un devoir c'est
un droit supprimer ce droit serait
terrible évidemment c'est l'intention de
personnes donc il faut l'utiliser Marie
guide du fait on a entendu que c'était
la faute aux déconfinement la photo
français qui pense aux vacances la faute
aux calendrier c'est jamais la faute des
politiques c'est jamais de poteau que
tout le monde a une part de
responsabilité et les élus aussi à tout
le monde a une part de responsabilité je
le pense alors que la région ne soit pas
suffisamment connue c'est une gifle que
nous recevons et que je reçois que je
pense que c'est pas spécifique à cette
région parce qu'il me semble que vous
les les interviews peuvent être d'une
autre région l'abstention à peu près
similaire au niveau national on entendra
la région c'est parce que c'est la
région on sait pas ce qu'elle nous
apporte donc on a tous une
responsabilité je pense que dans le plus
jeune âge au lycée il n'y a sûrement pas
assez d'instructions civique sur ce que
sont nos collectivités à quoi elles
servent je pense qu'on parle beaucoup
des présidentielles quand on parle du
système institutionnel auprès des jeunes
mais les collectivités locales on en
parle peu mais nous les élus alors nous
cherchons à communiquer sur ce que nous
avons fait peut-être nous ne faisons
passer c'est probable mais je pense
qu'il y a aussi un gouffre qui qui
s'installe entre
entre les élus et puis
la population qui est due à de la
déception qui est due au fait que
les élus ne sont pas toujours dans une
posture de de sincérité je pense que
c'est pour ça que je dis que nous avons
une part nous avons absolument une part
de responsabilité et quelle image
renvoyons-nous l'image de tout un chacun
est-ce que tout un chacun se reconnaît
dans le langage que nous avons dans les
propositions que nous faisons il faut
aussi que nous disent les élus sont pas
forcément sincère vous êtes pas sincère
mais c'est ce que j'entends on ne vous
croit pas vous ne tenez pas vos
engagements moi de mon côté j'essaye de
les tenir j'en ai pris en 2015 sans je
les ai tous tenues là je reprends 100
engagement que j'ai bien l'intention de
tenir et ça c'est peut-être la première
chose importante effectivement la
sincérité l'engagement j'ai le plâtre et
c'est une je disais votre voisine Mary
Gide Duffé est-ce que la gif vous l'avez
prise aussi cette abstention cette gifle
pour vous c'est un échec collectif c'est
certain il faut en chercher les causes
parce qu'on peut pas se contenter de ça
ça fait 30 ans maintenant qu'on dit
c'est un échec et finalement l'échec se
creuse alors pourquoi pourquoi est-ce
que nos concitoyens se détournent des
urnes pourquoi est-ce que finalement il
laisse choisir ce qui vote et alors
qu'ils sont de moins en moins nombreux
eux à voter j'ai pas l'explication et
personne ne l'a d'une manière précise
mais il me semble tout de même et c'est
un maire qui vous parle que plus vous
mettez de proximité entre les
institutions et les habitants plus vous
créez ce lien qui donne envie de choisir
moi je regrette infiniment que cette
région qui était avant 2015 d'un côté la
Franche-Comté et de l'autre la Bourgogne
soit devenu une grande région sans que
personne ne soit consulté madame Dufay
monsieur Patriat était comme l'arronzant
foire dans le bureau de Monsieur
Hollande pour réclamer cette fusion on
n'a pas consulté les habitants et du
coup on a éloigner la région des
citoyens on a augmenté les impôts on a
augmenté les frais de fonctionnement et
finalement personne ne s'y retrouve il
vous aura pas échappé que dans mon
projet je veux recoller au terrain avec
une région décentralisée avec des
maisons de la région dans chaque
département avec des élus qui seront sur
le terrain au contact des citoyens au
contact des mères pour essayer de
recréer ce lien de service public ce
lien démocratique dont nous avons besoin
2 milliards d'euros de budget et
personne ou si peu ne sait exactement ce
qu'est la région parce qu'elle est
passée sous les radars toutes ces
dernières années il y a peut-être un
chemin ici je ne dis pas que j'ai la
science infuse ni la recette miracle
mais il y a peut-être un chemin pour
recoller les électeurs à l'institution
régionale en décentralisant en se
rapprochant du terrain Bourgogne d'à
côté Franche-Comté de l'autre Julien
Oudoul 63% d'abstention c'est la faute à
qui
au-delà de la région nous vivons depuis
30 ans une crise de la démocratie on le
voit avec les chiffres de l'abstention
qui élections après l'élection
s'accroisse et ça on peut pas l'accepter
on peut pas l'accepter parce que je le
redis il y a évidemment un phénomène
extrêmement grave si un jour ou l'autre
il n'y a plus de votants il n'y aura
plus d'élection on ne demandera plus la
vie à nos concitoyens les décisions
viendront d'en haut les décisions seront
purement technocratiques et puis aussi
il y a si je puis dire la
technocratisation des collectivités des
politiques publiques si nos concitoyens
regardent des délibérations du conseil
régional de Bourgogne Franche-Comté
elles sont illisibles elles sont
totalement illisibles aux communs de nos
citoyens qui encore une fois ont besoin
de clarté ont besoin de savoir pourquoi
il vote ont besoin de savoir pourquoi il
paye aussi donc toutes les collectivités
non mais je veux dire c'est un ensemble
de facteurs c'est un ensemble de
facteurs chacun aille prendre sa part
évidemment moi ce que je regrette c'est
qu'il y a deux catégories le plus et
c'est les deux catégories finalement qui
sont les plus fragiles les jeunes qui se
sont abstenus massivement dimanche
dernier et les catégories populaires les
catégories populaires qui croient à tort
parce qu'on leur a fait croire que rien
ne changerait que le système finalement
est figé alors que les politiques qui
sont mises en œuvre finalement les
maltraitent les maltraitent socialement
les maltraitent démocratiquement mais
moi j'appelle un sursaut démocratique
qui est encore une fois est nécessaire
nécessaire pour que chaque pour que ça
change tout simplement parce que moi je
veux dire à nos compatriotes j'entends
votre colère j'entends votre
désenchantement qui est légitime au
regard de ce qui a été fait depuis 30
ans mais si vous n'allez pas voter rien
ne changera pourquoi c'est votre partie
qui est le plus touché par cette
abstention est-ce que finalement vous
êtes victime d'être devenu imparti comme
les autres boudé par ces électeurs il y
a trop de normalisations au
rassemblement national nous avons été
victime de l'abstention comme vous
l'avez dit plus que les autres 73% de
l'électorat du rassemblement national ne
s'est pas déplacé parce que notre
électorat est principalement issus des
catégories populaires notre électorat
donc
tout un tas de facteurs déjà notre
électorat est focalisé sur la
présidentielle parce qu'il a compris et
malheureusement c'est notre système
institutionnel qui est comme ça et qui a
été aussi voulu par Monsieur Macron qui
était voulu par le quinquennat il a
compris que tout se jouait à l'élection
présidentielle et que c'est l'élection
présidentielle qui était devenue
malheureusement je le dis
malheureusement l'alpha et l'oméga de la
politique nationale mais moi je dis à
nos électeurs parce que l'élection est
pas terminée on a tendance à faire
croire que cette élection est jouée non
les électeurs du RN peuvent gagner les
électeurs du RN s'ils se déplacent
dimanche peuvent changer les choses moi
j'attends de un sursaut démocratique
pour faire barrage à Madame Dufay pour
faire barrage à la gauche et aux
extrémistes verts
ce chiffre terrible 83% des 18 24 ans
n'ont pas voté pourquoi vous n'arrivez
pas à intéresser les jeunes
j'aurais posé la question hier soir je
suis allé voir de l'équipe de France
avec eux en terrasse et j'ai changé
beaucoup ne perçoivent pas d'abord
l'intérêt pour eux c'est voilà la région
de serpent et puis je pense qu'il faut
travailler et j'en ai parlé au milieu
intérieur sur vraiment un accélération
d'autres moyens de vote aujourd'hui nous
avons l'intelligence artificielle qui
peuvent nous permettre peut-être de nous
orienter vers d'autres moyens de vote
plus moderne le vote en ligne pourquoi
pas retravailler aussi sur le vote par
correspondance sont des choses qui
pourraient faciliter sur la distribution
les professionnels
personne ne l'est je disais simplement
qu'à chaque élection moi je n'ai pas
parfois eu les buts professions de foi
on en est tous victimes n'accusez pas
l'état je pense que le mouvement de la
majorité présidentielle est pas avantagé
les professions de foi et donc j'espère
qu'on les aura pour le deuxième tour
c'est aussi effectivement ce qu'elle
sans doute empêché de voter certains
la parole je vais vous la redonner vous
avez suivi une grosse pression de vos
adversaires depuis dimanche soir le
patron du Parti socialiste vous a
demandé de vous retirer le patron des
républicains vous avez une demande vous
a demandé de vous retirer finalement
vous êtes candidat en disant le risque
puisque c'est comme ça que vous le
considérez le risque FN est écarté ça
veut dire pour vous l'élection elle est
déjà jouée écoutez j'ai envie de
commencer à répondre à votre question
par une question même du fait même du
fait ce que vous estimez en danger
actuellement par ma présence
je ne qualifierais pas les choses ainsi
mais votre présence n'est pas
compréhensible au regard de toutes les
déclarations que vous aviez faites
auparavant alors je vais vous la faire
comprendre parce qu'être intelligent
c'est faire ses comptes et c'est aussi
observer observer que le rassemblement
national est beaucoup plus bas qui a 6
ans il y a 6 ans il était autour de 31%
vous étiez 3e vous a pris un risque
énorme vous avez gagné mais vous avez
pris votre risque énorme donc moi je
considère que le risque est très minime
aujourd'hui par rapport au chiffre
j'aurais sans doute choisi notre
solution vous savez j'ai reçu de
pression de personnes très franchement
monsieur Jacob m'a pas appelé monsieur
forme a pas appelé les donneurs de sonde
à partie socialiste qui s'est suicidé et
que j'ai quitté compte tenu aujourd'hui
du peu de poids qu'il a il y a même plus
de section du Parti socialiste à Nevers
ça vous donne l'idée monsieur Jacob qui
soutient monsieur platry qui s'est
alliac le traité le trait d'union le
trait d'union du Front national qui est
debout la France je pense qu'à ce
moment-là il faut demander aussi à
Monsieur plâtré de se retirer et puis
comparer avec la région Centre Val de
Loire nous sommes à quelques points dans
la même situation j'ai pas entendu
cryolu nous ne sommes pas ici en région
PACA faut pas tout mélanger donc je
considère qu'aujourd'hui j'ai d'abord un
électorat qui m'a porté vous considérez
que l'élection est jouée non je
considère que les pagesja nous avons un
million 300000 personnes qui ne sont pas
allés voter je considère qu'il peut y
avoir de grandes surprises si les
lectorattes mobilisent parce que
contrairement à ce que dit Monsieur
Odoul l'ensemble de nos mouvements et le
mien beaucoup n'a pas eu son électorat
dans les urnes donc rien n'est joué et
moi je vous dis qu'aujourd'hui c'est
important que je sois là parce que il y
a un électorat qui m'a fait confiance
qui ne se retrouvera sûrement pas dans
une gauche qui s'est Talia que l'extrême
gauche et dans une droite qui s'est
allée avec l'extrême droite vous mettez
tous les autres Bourguignons francontois
ou donc je suis une solution et je vais
même aller plus loin je pense que ma
présence non je termine je pense que ma
présence ma présence si elle n'était
plus là aurait augmenté l'abstention et
aurait augmenté le Front national j'ai
une plâtré sur l'abstention et le
maintien de Monsieur turio puisque le
président de votre partie lui a demandé
de se retirer j'ai d'ailleurs réaliser
dans le débat tout de suite que
Christian Jacob serait à Dijon avec
François Baroin ce soir même pour me
soutenir bah écoutez non mais après tout
ce sont des leaders qui s'engagent et on
est dans un débat démocratique et c'est
bien légitime je pense que vous n'avez
pas manqué de soutien puisque
visiblement les ministres ont beaucoup
de temps à passer en campagne et sont
venus abondamment vous soutenir ceci
étant dit sans vouloir faire un jour à
Monsieur Thuriot contre lequel je n'ai
absolument aucun grief il sait très bien
que personne dans l'histoire politique
française n'est jamais passé de 11 à 35%
entre les deux tours ça n'est pas lui
faire un jour que de dire que il ne
gagnera pas cette élection je me
garderai bien de fanfaronner en disant
que je vais la gagner ça je vais aller
ça à ceux qui roulent des mécaniques il
faut être très humble par rapport à ce
que les électeurs décident mais pour
autant il est une évidence que on a
aucune chance en votant monsieur turiou
d'accéder à la présidence de la région
après les électeurs sont souverains
personne n'en est propriétaire donc
chacun se terminera je pense que l'offre
politique en fait elle est plutôt claire
dans ce débat monsieur Thuriot ne peut
pas gagner et d'ailleurs monsieur
Patriat disait chez vos confrères de
Public Sénat lundi matin que leur
objectif c'était finalement de ne pas
redescendre en deçà de 11% de conserver
ses 11% du premier tour on voit bien
donc il n'y a aucune logique de gagne
là-dedans le rassemblement national est
au taquet il ne regagnera pas que pas
plus d'ailleurs qu'il y a 6 ans des
électeurs au deuxième tour il sera 25
26% pas davantage et bien voilà nous
voici dans un duel madame Dufay entre la
droite républicaine que certains
trouvent trop à droite comme Monsieur
Thuriot mais que j'ai essayé
d'équilibrer avec les centrices avec le
mouvement écologiste indépendant et la
gauche j'allais dire quelle gauche le
Parti socialiste dans l'état où il se
trouve qui est obligé de s'appuyer sur
des verres qui demain tiendront la
majorité puisque avec huit élus
d'extrême gauche vert madame Dufay ne
pourra rien faire sans le raccord elle
le sait elle a pris son risque pour
essayer de colmater les fuites du bateau
région mais pour autant nous sommes dans
une confrontation droite-gauche et c'est
ce que les électeurs ont à trancher
dimanche Julien
avec Monsieur Thuriot à part peut-être
qu'on aime le foot tous les deux je suis
un opposant farouche de la République en
marche en revanche moi je suis un
démocrate les électeurs de Monsieur
turio l'ont qualifié pour le second tour
ça veut dire que les électeurs de
Monsieur turio souhaitent que le
mouvement de Monsieur thurious soit
représenté au sein de l'assemblée
régionale tout cela c'est la démocratie
donc moi je ne comprends pas ces
pressions ces désistement ces fusions
ces méthodes pour faire barrage à un
moment donné il y a un principe on est à
la proportionnelle ou pas les électeurs
font leur choix et ils veulent que
certains courants politiques puissent
les représenter au conseil régional donc
moi je trouve tout à fait normal que
Monsieur Turiot soit présent et ensuite
sur les enjeux de ce scrutin ils sont
clairs les électeurs de Bourgogne
Franche-Comté alors que 70% des
électeurs du RN ne sont pas déplacés non
désignés comme le principal opposant
madame du fait et comme l'alternance à
Madame Dufay donc moi j'appelle un large
rassemblement car je suis le seul en
capacité de gagner cette élection face à
même du fait
probablement évidemment de nos électeurs
qui ne sont pas allés voter et je les
enjoint à prendre le chemin des urnes
dimanche et puis le rassemblement de
sous tous ces électeurs de droite qui ne
veulent pas de la gauche l'extrême
gauche la responsabilité c'est
d'empêcher 6 années avec ses écolos
Dingo qui vont mettre en place justement
à la fois nos entreprises les
automobilistes notre identité nos
terroirs à un moment donné il faut
prendre en responsabilité ce scrutin et
se rassembler pour empêcher pour
reprendre les mots de vos adversaires
serait vos otages des écolos Dingo
parce que j'entends des mots les dingos
les extrémistes les merveilles non mais
d'abord un peu de respect déjà pour les
électeurs qui vont voter pour cette
composante de notre démocratie que sont
les vers et les écologistes après que je
sois l'otage la prisonnière je sais pas
où est-ce que vous avez trouvé cela
j'étais avec les Verts en 2010 j'étais
avec les Verts enfin en 2010 avant 2010
quand j'ai pris la succession de Raymond
Fourny en 2008 de 2008 à 2010 puis
ensuite en 2010 ou les vers m'ont
rejoint effectivement au deuxième tour
comme ici et nous avons mis en place des
politiques structurantes en matière de
biodiversité d'efficacité énergétique
dont je suis fier et qui sont encore en
cours et je n'ai jamais été prisonnière
de quiconque d'ailleurs les Verts m'ont
rejoint sur mon programme mon programme
n'a pas été fondamentalement chamboulé
parce que les vers sont venus nous
rejoindre nous avons renforcé nous avons
renforcé un certain nombre de choses
donc franchement arrêtez vos expressions
et Dingo mais Dingo Dingo vous croyez
pas que Dingo c'est de vouloir que c'est
de vouloir démanteler les éoliennes sur
notre territoire
et les punaises de lit quand des élus
Verts demandent de retirer le sapin de
Noël qui qualifie d'arbre mort quand des
élus Verts demandent des menus sans
viande à la cantine quand des élus Verts
veulent exclure le Tour de France quand
des élus Verts financent des mosquées
radicales c'est ce que j'appelle un
danger à la fois pour nos terroirs pour
notre identité pour notre économie mais
aussi pour la République car comme le
disait votre collègue anidalgo oui les
Verts ont un problème avec la République
madame du fait vous êtes dans la
caricature ce sont les faits c'est le
bilan des municipalités gérées par
Europe Écologie Les Verts qui sont
totalement folles et aujourd'hui les
électeurs voient la réalité
si vous êtes élus dimanche donc ça je
pense que les Bourguignons et les
Franc-Comtois n'en veulent pas moi j'ai
eu des appels à la fois transporteur
routier à la fois de l'agriculteur que
ce soit pour les prédateurs à la fois
pour les quotas parce que les quotas va
plomber les contenir 30 000 emplois on y
reviendra merci
grande parole à la fin attention je vous
propose de parler à présent de la
compétence majeure du conseil régional
on va parler un peu de fond également
c'est le développement économique avec
bien sûr cette actualité avant-hier la
fonderie MBF fonderie emblématique de
Saint-Claude c'est l'une des dernières
de France a été liquide et 280 salariés
sont sur le carreau se sous-traitant
automobile travaillait pour Renault et
pour PSA notamment c'est une entreprise
de Saint-Claude dans le Jura
emblématique de Saint-Claude
emblématique aussi des difficultés de
notre industrie je vous propose
d'écouter la rage vraiment la rage des
salariés c'était à la sortie du tribunal
de commerce de Dijon avant-hier mardi
Bruno Le Maire Agnès renacher au lieu de
rester ministre là reconvertissez-vous
en chauffeur de corbillard voilà c'est
ce que vous êtes exactement les
politiques vous êtes tous des
vous êtes des voleurs les politiciens de
merde qui vous êtes un service de nous
venez fils de chien
c'est pour ça qu'il y a de l'abstention
vous êtes ça des milliers des milliers
ça vous êtes
par guide du fait c'est proposons sont
extrêmement durs est-ce que vous vous
sentez responsable
dans cette affaire qui est un malheur un
grand malheur pour les salariés pour les
familles pour le territoire de
Saint-Claude la région est là tout fait
ce qu'elle pouvait faire elle a poussé
tous les feux premièrement prendre en
charge les salaires dans une entreprise
en difficulté le temps que le tribunal
de commerce examine des offres de
repreneur parce qu'à ce moment-là il y
en avait trois
ensuite la région a proposé d'entrer
dans le capital d'une future entité à
constituer et de chercher un pool
d'investisseur pour cette future entité
nous avions besoin de temps
supplémentaires ce temps n'a pas été
donné compte tenu de la situation
financière difficile de l'entreprise
mais voyant que le tribunal à les
statuer et qu'il n'y avait qu'un
repreneur un repreneur qui n'était pas
soutenu par l'État je me suis
désolidarisée de l'État pour soutenir
cette unique repreneur et lui proposer
que si son offre était retenue par le
tribunal nous entrions au capital de son
entreprise et que nous lui a Amions les
fonds nécessaires pour l'investissement
donc nous avons tout tout un échec
aujourd'hui ça veut dire que les
politiques sont impuissants dans ce
genre de dossier je pense que l'état de
la de l'entreprise était catastrophique
excusez-moi mais quand on a la gestion
qu'il y a eu dans cette entreprise
depuis 5 ans une entreprise dans
laquelle nous n'avions pas à intervenir
parce que dire que on n'a pas su contrer
le management de cette entreprise il
n'appartient pas à une région
d'intervenir dans le management de
l'entreprise et donc cette région a été
mise en faillite sciemment par les
dirigeants précédents quand vous héritez
de cela c'est quand même très très
difficile alors qu'il y a de la
technologie des machines du savoir-faire
dans un secteur qui est aujourd'hui
extrêmement sinistré puisque c'est le
secteur lié à l'industrie automobile et
au basculement du moteur thermique au
moteur électrique ça c'est sûr mais moi
je dis qu'aujourd'hui dans la crise des
fonderies en France s'il y avait une
fonderie qui ne devait pas fermer c'est
bien celle-ci parce qu'à Saint Claude à
Saint-Claude territoire enclavé il est
quand même très difficile de reclasser
les gens alors on va on va être aux
côtés de l'État qui met des moyens très
très important je n'ai jamais vu des
moyens aussi importants c'est des moyens
exceptionnels et donc la région sera
forcément aux côtés de l'étain Denis
turio les salariés qu'on a entendu sont
très virulents à l'égard de certains
membres du gouvernement l'État et Tail
en cause dans cette affaire je ne pense
pas je pense que un emploi toujours une
victoire de 180 personnes et leur
famille concernées c'est une lourde
défaite lourde défaite et il faut
assumer des choses il faut surtout se
servir du fond de reconversion de 50
millions pour la fonderie et donc il
sera notamment orienté de façon
prioritaire vis-à-vis de ses salariés
s'il n'y a pas d'autres solutions je
pense qu'il y en a peut-être une je veux
pas laisser courir de faux espoirs une
entreprise d'abord c'est un chef
d'entreprise qui la dirige c'est pas une
collectivité après si les mauvais choix
ont été fait par contre ça veut dire que
il y a pas eu d'accompagnement suffisant
la région et là pour accompagner et
c'est pour ça que dans mon programme moi
je souhaite associer les branches
professionnelles à la définition de la
pub économique pendant 6 ans et pas les
prendre à témoins quand c'est trop tard
il faut qu'on arrête d'être les pompiers
faut qu'on soit dans l'anticipation
qu'on aide les entreprises à prendre les
bons choix et là en l'occurrence il y
avait eu des bons choix qui ont été
faits mais je le dis
s'est associée et c'est pour ça que la
région s'était engagée à garantir les
salaires parce que l'État est derrière
et je voudrais rappeler une chose c'est
que c'est une décision de justice qui a
décidé c'est pas le gouvernement vous le
savez la justice est indépendante et
malheureusement le tribunal de commerce
n'avait fait qu'un petit renvoi de 8
jours qui rendait impossible de trouver
un preneur ça fait des mois l'État avait
gelé une dette de 10 millions d'euros 10
millions d'euros pour pas mettre
l'entreprise en difficulté il y avait
besoin d'un peu de temps et ce temps
lavé puisque l'État financer les
salaires avec la région donc je ne
comprends pas cette brutalité mais il y
a encore possibilité d'un appel et moi
je pense qu'il faudrait le faire
est-ce que c'est le rôle d'un conseil
régional d'investir dans des entreprises
privées c'est d'abord le rôle d'un
conseil régional de dire à l'état quand
il fait des bêtises
cette affaire elle est née il y a
quelques années lorsque la France parce
qu'il y a l'idéologie verte en
l'occurrence je suis désolé d'y revenir
a décidé d'interdire les moteurs
thermiques et diesel sans accompagnement
de la filière et c'est exactement
européen pour l'autre la France écoutez
il appartient à la France est une nation
souveraine et de protéger son industrie
voilà des décennies qu'on la laisse
partir à l'étranger et là on accepte que
40% des fonderies françaises c'est pas
moi qui le dit ce sont les rapports
officiels qui ont été produits par le
gouvernement vont dégraisser et
disparaître avec leurs emplois donc le
rôle de la région ça n'est pas
d'encourager un état qui détruit
l'industrie sauf que la fonderie en
question
elle produit des pièces pour les moteurs
qui ne sont pas thermique hydrogène des
choses
simplement que nous ne pouvons pas être
les bras ballants devant des décisions
nationales qui impactent une région
qui est très industrielle ça veut dire
concrètement que demain puisque
s'il faut investir je l'ai déjà dit
d'ailleurs j'y suis tout à fait
favorable mais nous devons prendre les
devants sans quoi nous courons toujours
sur cette case sociale qui laissera un
manquablement du monde sur le carreau
Julien audoulay est-ce qu'on l'espère le
marché ou est-ce qu'on aide ces
entreprises si oui lesquelles est dans
quel secteur
sur la liquidation des mbrf à
Saint-Claude les questions qui se posent
c'est à quoi sert la région à quoi sert
la proximité de la candidate sortante
avec le président de la République et
finalement la trahison parce qu'il
s'agit d'une trahison elle pose la
question du respect de la parole
publique madame Dufay a fait énormément
de promesses madame Dufay s'est servi de
la détresse des salariés de MBF pour un
outil électoral pour une promesse
électorale et quand on voit ce qui s'est
passé avant-hier
quand on voit qu'en parallèle madame du
fait est en train de distribuer les
postes pour ses amis extrémistes verts
on voit là tout le finalement toute
l'incompétence le mensonge et la
trahison qui a été celui de la majorité
sortant
un fond souverain régional parce que
finalement prend les choses à l'envers
elle disait on attend que l'investisseur
donc monsieur Azoulay soit soutenu par
l'État et ensuite on entrera au capital
il fallait que la région entre d'abord
au capital que la région soit
volontariste qu'elle soit protectrice et
ça ne date pas
la région doit être un bouclier social
et industriel je pense compte tenu de la
gravité de la situation nous sommes en
pleine crise économique 15000 emplois
ont été détruits 15000 emplois ont été
détruits depuis un an si on prend la
période 2010 à 2015 30 000 emplois ont
été détruits à 39 industriels cet argent
le trouve où cet argent déjà on le
trouve en faisant des économies
notre groupe rassemblement national a
fait à chaque session budgétaire des
économies colossales sur tous les sujets
des subventions qui me concernent pas la
région solidarité internationale
formation des migrants communication des
réguliers art contemporains et autres ça
ne concerne pas le quotidien de nos
compatriotes moi je souhaite remettre
l'argent au bon endroit et je souhaite
que la région agisse pas qu'elle se
contente de pleurer sur le lait renversé
ça a été la politique de Madame Dufay
qu'est-ce qui a été fait par la région
concrètement pour anticiper MBF il
fallait anticiper depuis des mois là
aujourd'hui on voit le drame social le
drame industriel et le drame humain
parce que peut-être que pour Madame
panier runacher la ministre ce ne sont
que des statistiques mais là c'est des
hommes et des femmes c'est des hommes et
des femmes qui sont aujourd'hui dans la
détresse dans l'angoisse et qui voit que
les responsables politiques n'agissent
merci
vous répondez très rapidement
de se servir de cette affaire dans un
but électoral c'est intolérable est-ce
moi
a décidé du calendrier de cette affaire
ça tombe très très mal mais là vraiment
vous exploitez les choses d'une façon
honteuse après je vous entends dire il
fallait mettre de l'argent on va créer
un fond souverain il fallait mettre de
l'argent et Madame Dufay a pas mis
l'argent mais on met de l'argent dans
une entreprise
l'entreprise elle n'existe plus donc il
y a un repreneur il faut qu'on ait le
projet du repreneur pour pouvoir mettre
de l'argent dans ce dans ce projet si le
tribunal de commerce avait statué pour
ce repreneur
mais l'anticipation nous l'avons fait
l'anticipation nous l'avons faite parce
que pour pouvoir mettre de l'argent dans
le capital d'une entreprise il faut une
expertise indépendante et nous avons
pris les moyens de diligenter cette
exporte cette expertise si jamais si
jamais le tribunal de commerce avait pu
retenir l'offre nous étions près
malheureusement
les choses ne sont pas ne se sont pas
ainsi faites merci beaucoup je vous
propose qu'on on avance un peu et qu'on
aille un petit peu plus loin avec un
secteur qui se porte bien et pourtant
vous allez l'entendre on a rencontré un
chef d'entreprise qui a un gros souci on
l'écoute et on en discute juste après
bonjour Michel Liardet patron
d'européenne de condiment on est le
deuxième producteur de moutarde en
France avec plus de 25000 tonnes
produites par an avec notre marque phare
bornier aujourd'hui moi je voudrais
poser une question à la région savoir en
fait comment on peut nous aider au
niveau recrutement c'est un vrai
problème aujourd'hui sur quasiment tous
les posts on a énormément de problèmes
de recrutement que ce soit pour des
caristes on n'est pas la seule
entreprise dans la région
que ce soit pour des opérateurs de
conditionnement que ce soit pour des
cadres également en termes
d'attractivité de la région donc
qu'est-ce que peut faire la région
Bourgogne Franche-Comté pour nous aider
et nous on veut du concret du pratique
de l'opérationnel on veut du concret
Gilles platrer comment aider
concrètement les chefs d'entreprise de
la région qui peinent à recruter c'est
bien c'est bien un des enjeux du mandat
qui va s'ouvrir comment est-ce qu'on
fait de la région un véritable
partenaire de la croissance économique
d'abord une région qui doit être modeste
et active moi j'ai inscrit d'emblée dans
notre projet une baisse de la fiscalité
on l'a terriblement augmenté vous savez
que l'un des leviers c'est la fiscalité
sur les cartes grises nous la baisserons
au niveau où elle était avant la fusion
et demain il faut une région encore plus
partenaire ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que nous réunirons les branches
professionnelles régulièrement et pas
simplement avec les agents de la région
mais avec les élus et en particulier le
président de région que je serai pour
pouvoir définir avec eux les besoins
notamment en termes de main d'oeuvre
mais pas simplement en matière
d'investissement en matière de mutation
technologique en matière d'immersion
dans les bassins d'emploi qui sont ceux
de notre région et il faut alors là
c'est un reproche énorme que j'adresse à
cette majorité je sais que ça déplairera
à Madame Dufay mais rien ou pratiquement
rien n'a été fait en matière
d'orientation professionnelle nous avons
à peine 1% notre budget général 0,7%
consacré à cet objet vous avez un
chômage des jeunes de 20% dans la région
et vous avez comme le chef d'entreprise
qui vient de parler des centaines voire
des milliers de chefs d'entreprises qui
ne trouvent pas de main d'oeuvre
qualifiées à embaucher même en CDI même
avec des salaires très appréciables
demain ça veut dire quoi qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'une politique d'orientation
professionnelle ambitieuse c'est une
politique qui fait rentrer les
entreprises dans le système éducatif
c'est une entreprise qui en partie une
région qui en particulier demande aux
jeunes qui viennent d'entrer dans la
carrière d'aller présenter leurs
filières qui recrutent recrutent aux
jeunes des lycées voire même en
partenariat avec les départements il y a
aucun partenariat Région Département
pour le moment avec les lycéens donc
c'est une politique offensive exactement
l'inverse de celle qui a été conduite et
qui nous conduit à cette situation
abracam montres merci Gilles plâtré
denituriaux à vos mesures prioritaires
pour aider ces chefs d'entreprise qui
n'arrivent pas embaucher on a vu tout à
l'heure une entreprise malheureusement
en difficulté pas forcément pour les
problèmes de recrutement mais il y en a
beaucoup comme votre exemple qui ne
demande qu'à se développer et qui ont
des difficultés de recrutement quand
même du fait n'a jamais posé son bilan
de ce qui a été réalisé pendant 6 ans et
notamment de ce qu'elle a mis ou pas en
œuvre sur l'innovation il y a beaucoup
d'entreprises innovantes et il y a
malheureusement pas la main d'oeuvre
adéquate nous nous engageons à faire de
la formation de proximité Dijon et
Besançon sont importants mais nous
devons définir l'offre de formation avec
les présidents qui ne dialogue pas
actuellement avec la région ils me l'ont
dit avec les organismes de formation et
surtout orienter les formations aux bons
endroits une entreprise qui n'arrive pas
à recruter dans un bassin de territoire
de la bassin de vie c'est parce qu'il y
a pas des jeunes qui sont formés à côté
ou alors que l'entreprise n'est pas
connue il faut que les entreprises ou
leurs portes mais ça de plus en plus de
chefs d'entreprise le font et nous
devons définis notre programme un
territoire d'entreprise c'est plus la
région qui définit les choses ça remonte
du terrain et par les élus régionaux et
par les personnes de la région nous
serons vraiment sur quelque chose de
beaucoup plus fin je voulais dire que la
région aujourd'hui a augmenté de 15
millions d'euros sur le mandat le coup
salarial le coût qui donc ne bénéficie
pas au territoire avec ce coup on
pourrait développer des campus connectés
des tiers-lieux de la formation vraiment
dans des petits endroits ruraux qui se
sentent oubliés qui finalement votre
rassemblement national bien souvent
alors qu'il n'en aucune envie quelque
part donc c'est ça que nous souhaitons
développer plus de proximité plus
d'égalité plus d'équité pour tous les
territoires je lui endoune sur la
formation professionnelle faut-il
adapter les formations aux demandes des
jeunes ou aux demandes des entreprises
je tiens juste à dire monsieur Thuriot
pour le rassurer quand les gens votent à
son national c'est qu'ils en ont envie
on les force pas toujours heureusement
ils en ont envie c'est leur choix et il
faut le respecter comme chaque électeur
pour la région pour en matière de
formation qui relie la question de
l'attractivité aussi qui relie la
question des besoins évidemment il faut
que la région favorise le terreau et il
faut que la région mette l'argent public
au bon endroit parce que malheureusement
de l'argent public est gaspillé
gaspiller dans des entreprises qui ne
font pas le choix du local qui ne font
pas le choix de recruter de préserver
l'emploi local ça a été le cas tout au
long du mandat on l'a dénoncé
régulièrement je me rappelle d'ailleurs
d'un déplacement dans une entreprise
forestière dans le Morvan subventionné
par la région qui faisait appel à des
travailleurs détachés des pays de l'Est
qui dormaient d'ailleurs à même le sol
et qui faisait venir sa production de
sapin de Noël du Danemark et ce qu'on
peut concevoir que l'argent public
l'argent des Bourguignons des Francs
comptoirs favorise à la fois le travail
détaché et en même temps des productions
qui ne sont pas de la région évidemment
non moi il y aura des critères
extrêmement précis pour favoriser le
recrutement de nos jeunes parce
qu'encore une fois je considère qu'il y
a une grave discrimination aujourd'hui
qui va s'accentuer avec les politiques
qui vont être mises en œuvre que nos
jeunes sont soit concurrencés et
notamment par une main d'oeuvre
issue de l'étranger une main d'oeuvre de
migrants notamment dernièrement il y a
une actualité qui m'a quelque peu
révolté 12 migrants qui ont été
embauchés à PSA Vesoul dans des postes
de préparateur de commande alors qu'il y
a des centaines de Français de jeunes
Françaises et Français qui attendent ces
postes qui étaient là pour ces postes
malheureusement on avait fait passer
d'autres et la politique migratoire de
Madame Dufay parce que Madame Dufay
parle beaucoup de la sécurité comme
n'étant pas une compétence régionale
malheureusement la fête d'immigration
une compétence régionale ce que ne
veulent pas les Bourguignons et les
Franc-Comtois ce qui fait passer encore
une fois nos jeunes après les migrants
avec des discriminations les injustices
totales Marie guide Dufer en matière de
formation et d'apprentissage la région
ne fait pas assez la région gaspi
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à vos
adversaires je vais reprendre la région
ne travaille pas avec les branches
professionnelles donc elle est à côté
des besoins
d'où travaillons de façon constante avec
les branches professionnelles nous avons
un dialogue régulier structuré
mais en plus il est pas au niveau
régional ce dialogue il est territoire
par territoire c'est-à-dire que sur tout
sur chaque bassin d'emploi nous
identifions avec les branches
professionnelles avec les chefs
d'entreprise les besoins et nous mettons
en face les formations je peux vous
citer des formations sur tous les
territoires qui sont mis en place
spécifiquement comme de la dentelle pour
répondre aux besoins des chefs
d'entreprise à côté ça ne marche pas
partout
j'entends dire que ce que je vous dis
n'est pas fait donc je restitue c'est
fait après il y a un problème qui est
pas un problème spécifiquement Bourgogne
Franche-Comté qui est un problème
national une comment dire une
désinfection par rapport au métier
technique par rapport au métier manuel
par rapport au métier industriel cette
désaffection elle est générale elle
renvoie effectivement à des questions
d'orientation elle renvoie à des
questions de connaissances des métiers
pour lesquels il faut absolument
multiplier des occasions des
opportunités d'ailleurs innovantes pour
immerger les jeunes les jeunes des
collèges les jeunes des lycées dans la
réalité des métiers donc non seulement
des visites d'entreprises mais on a
aussi développé des l'achat de casques
virtuels dans les lycées qui plongent
nos jeunes dans la réalité virtuelle des
métiers pour les leur faire connaître
j'entends monsieur plâtré qui dit moi
quand je serai en responsabilité je
ferai témoigner des jeunes pour d'autres
jeunes sur leur fierté de tels métiers
nous l'avons fait dans les salles de
cinéma de toute la Bourgogne
Franche-Comté nous avons fait appel à
des jeunes nous avons fait appel à des
jeunes mais je vous parle des milieux
scolaires nous avons fait appel à des
jeunes qui parlent à d'autres qui leur
montrent la fierté d'avoir choisi les
métiers de l'industrie donc il faut
continuer mais il y a un vrai sujet qui
est un sujet de connaissance des métiers
merci Marie guide du fait Stéphane Paris
notre partenaire de France Bleu va nous
rejoindre dans un instant Stéphane vous
avez sélectionné plusieurs questions
d'auditeur alors on va demander à chacun
de nos candidats de répondre très
clairement et très brièvement c'est à
VOUS Stéphane bonsoir bonsoir Elsa
bonsoir à tous oui trois questions à
partir des 1800 propositions les
séparent les auditeurs de France Bleu
sur la plateforme make.org
#ma solution alors des interrogations
qui résument les priorités des auditeurs
sur l'environnement l'agriculture le
soutien aux filières courtes je vais
vous poser à tous les quatre ces trois
questions et je vais vous demander d'y
répondre assez brièvement 10 à 15
secondes oui non d'accord pas d'accord
je commence par vous madame Dufay
première question d'un auditeur Georges
de talent de
la charge de talent donc en Côte d'Or et
Philippe De Villers sur saulno en
Haute-Saône faut-il financer davantage
l'isolation des bâtiments dans le cadre
de la lutte contre le changement
climatique absolument absolument depuis
2013 nous avons un programme il
s'appelle effilogie où nous aidons à
faire des diagnostics pour voir quels
sont les travaux d'isolation à faire
dans les bâtiments où nous allons même
jusqu'à financer une partie de ces
travaux pour les familles les plus
modestes il faut continuer accélérer
pousser économiser l'énergie c'est
essentiel Gilles plâtré oui la réponse
est oui d'ailleurs vous le retrouvez en
toute lettre dans mon projet on a on est
confronté un changement climatique nous
devons absolument adapter nos modes de
vie donc la réponse est totalement oui
en mettant le paquet juste par rapport à
ce que vient de dire Madame buffet très
tout simplement est très court en
mettant des règlements accessibles au
grand public ce qui n'est absolument pas
le cas en ce moment denituriaux oui non
réponse oui je le fais déjà au niveau de
l'intercommunalité les régions le font
l'état aussi l'ANA le fait c'est évident
qu'on doit tous être dans cette que les
factures arrêtent parfois de coûter plus
cher que les loyers Julien audoul
faut-il mettre des moyens sur
l'isolation des bâtiments la réponse est
oui bien évidemment c'est l'une des
mesures pour lutter contre la précarité
énergétique et la région doit mettre de
l'argent là-dedans certainement pas pour
le développement de l'éolien qui est une
arnaque écologique donc vous êtes tous
d'accord deuxième question posez par
André de Molène dans l'Yonne faut-il
développer le bio et l'équitable dans
les cantines on va faire l'inverse on va
commencer par vous Julien Oudoul il faut
il faut surtout développer le local oui
au bio mais surtout le local est dans
d'ailleurs dans mon projet c'est 100% de
viande et légumes
issus de production locale c'est bon
pour la santé des lycéens c'est bon pour
les revenus des agriculteurs donc oui
pour le local mais non pour le bio si
bio et local mais je préfère le local
parce que vous savez en termes de
nutrition vaut mieux du local et du bon
plutôt que du bio qui vient du bout du
monde de nettoyo oui pour le bio dans
les cantines tout ce qui est bon pour la
santé il faut le savourer donc oui mais
il faut aller au-delà parce que Monsieur
Odoul promet des choses qui ne pourra
pas tenir la plupart de nos maraîchers
n'ont pas suffisamment de production
très très compliqué de faire bouger les
habitudes dans les lycées nous n'avons
pas la responsabilité directe sur les
intendants et les cuisiniers qui font
les choix dans les lycées mais nous
devons pousser absolument pour aller
dans ce sens là merci Marie guide du
fait troisième et dernière question
posée par Fatma de Héricourt en
Haute-Saône faut-il contraindre les
médecins à s'installer dans les déserts
médicaux je commence avec vous Gilles
platrais vous avez déjà parlé oui bien
sûr
la désertification médicale c'est un
enjeu énorme je suis heureux que
d'ailleurs on en parle à la faveur de
cette question il y a des solutions qui
existent des médecins salariés la région
peut aider lorsque les libéraux sont
défaillants des unités mobiles de
télémédecine ce sont des cabinets avec
une infirmière et un médecin qui peut
faire un diagnostic à distance ces
solutions sont là nous les avons mis
dans notre programme et nous irons parce
que c'est un enjeu majeur Majeur mais on
peut les aider qui viennent peu
contraindre par la loi on peut
contraindre pas la région mais la région
peut aider les collectivités dans les
initiatives que je viens de citer et ça
sera pour le bien de tout le monde
donutorio il faut les inciter fortement
moi je n'aurais rien contre qu'un
médecin qui est formé sur un territoire
engagé pendant quelques temps il y a
quand une partie de la formation qui est
payée ça me semblerait une bonne chose
faut qu'on en finisse avec cette
problématique on peut pallier un peu
avec la 5G sur la télécabine la
télémédecine la téléconsultation mais ça
ne suffira pas on a quelque chose de
très concret aussi dans notre programme
ce sont les internats ruraux quand un
médecin fait un stage ou un interne fait
un stage dans un cabinet de médecine il
retourne en général vivre dans la grande
ville mais là il faut qu'il puisse vivre
dans la ville où il pourrait s'installer
donc je pense que chacun a cet effort à
faire est-ce qu'on peut contraindre
Julien Oudoul les médecins s'installer
dans les déserts médicaux contraindre
non pas au niveau de la région en
revanche on peut les inciter forcément
et moi bien sûr et moi élu président de
région je recruterai 200 médecins
salariés pour travailler dans les
territoires ruraux ou des certifiés oui
avec une ligne de bus médicalisée pour
aller au plus près des personnes les
plus fragiles les personnes âgées les
personnes handicapées je tiens à dire
que la télémédecine c'est aussi une
bonne chose sauf qu'il faut la 5G et
pour la 5G il faut certainement pas les
Verts qui sont contre ce progrès elle
arrive quand même la 5G on termine avec
vous Marie guide du fait faut-il
contraindre les médecins s'installer
dans les déserts médicaux une position
nationale de contraindre les médecins la
région peut faire quelque chose non la
région elle peut pas contraindre elle
peut inciter elle peut inciter elle peut
pousser des médecins à s'installer en
milieu rural et notre mode d'incitation
au niveau de
la majorité qui était la mienne et de la
liste que je pousse c'est d'accompagner
les maisons de santé qui regroupent
plusieurs disciplines dans des bourses
qui peuvent mettre à disposition ainsi
des habitants en milieu rural de la
médecine générale des kinés des
infirmières et certains membres de
spécialités merci merci Stéphane Jérémy
on poursuit on parle de désert médicaux
on va parler madame messieurs de nos
campagnes nous sommes vous le savez la
région la plus rurale de France avec
plus de la moitié des habitants qui
vivent en dehors des villes comment
aider nos campagnes et puis comment
lutter plus généralement contre le
sentiment d'abandon que ressentent les
ruraux on commence avec vous de nieterio
par la proximité la proximité elle a un
coût mais c'est le coup de la démocratie
quand on l'ignore et bien on en paye les
conséquences notamment sur l'extrême
droite et pour moi évidemment je viens
d'un territoire pratiquement rural
canadien donc je sais un peu ce dont je
parle il faut faire davantage d'efforts
vers nos territoires ruraux qui ont
besoin de la force des grandes villes
qui ont besoin des villes médianes mais
le dispositif de l'État pour les centres
bourgs bientôt pour les petites villes
de demain ce sont des axes intéressants
moi je suis ville aussi coeur de ville
donc ça m'a permis d'accélérer la région
doit abonder la région doit rajouter et
la région est peu endettés et elle ne
l'a pas fait pendant cette mandature la
région de la région de la région doit
payer les derniers kilomètres de fibres
et Communauté de Communes n'y arrivent
pas malgré les financements de France
numérique en plus elles ne seront pas
propriétés infrastructures aujourd'hui
pour un habitant de Bourgogne
Franche-Comté la fibre c'est comme l'eau
courante et s'il ne l'a pas il se sent
méprisé donc il faut se battre pour cela
on parlait de 5g moi je suis pour la 5G
raisonnable parce qu'elle apporte mieux
de sécurité mieux de santé je travaille
ce déploiement avec Cédrico sur les
zones prudence 25% nos opérateurs
doivent le faire dans les zones peu
dense pour 25%. il faut tenir cet
engagement bref il faut concerner nos
habitants partout y compris dans les
plus terribles dans les plus petits
territoires nous le priorisons ça me
semble indispensable
plus de la proximité et plus de fibres
en jeu majeur parce qu'on est un
tournant si on ne met pas le paquet sur
la ruralité maintenant des choses vont
se passer qui vont condamner nos
paysages et les habitants qui en
profitent à des évolutions qu'ils n'ont
pas décidé j'ai pris un engagement dans
cette campagne si je suis élu président
il y aura un vice-président chargé de la
défense de la réalité et de ses
traditions ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que par rapport à la majorité que
Madame buffet voudrait constituer nous
soutiendrons ceux qui défendent la
réalité sur le terrain les agriculteurs
les chasseurs l'ensemble des
agriculteurs en tout cas pas
correctement si j'en crois toutes les
remontées que j'ai sur le terrain quant
au chasseur allait donc demander à son
allié madame mode qui a signé la charte
de L214 ce qu'elle en pense donc nous
avons besoin de défendre les acteurs de
la réalité ça veut dire concrètement et
ça implique aussi la défense de nos
paysages nous ne pouvons pas devenir une
réserve allez éolienne cette énergie non
pilotable décidée par l'idéologie des
Verts à laquelle souscrit madame Dufay
comme Monsieur turio d'ailleurs
puisqu'ils sont d'accord sur ce point
donc on a un vrai projet de défense la
réalité si nous ne faisons pas ça demain
vous aurez des gens qui viendront des
centres-villes d'ailleurs ce qu'on
appelle vaguement les bobos qui nous
dirons à nous qui vivons dans la réalité
et bien vous devez vivre de telle façon
ça c'est hors de question c'est presque
une question de civilisation en tout cas
nous on a décidé d'y consacrer du temps
des moyens et donc une délégation
spécifique sur la défense de la réalité
la réponse de Marie guide Dufay vous ne
dépend vous ne défendez pas les
chasseurs vous ne défendez pas dans la
rue des agriculteurs comme une région
extrêmement rurale la plus grande région
rurale de France donc forcément c'est
une grande priorité de la région et donc
cela s'est manifesté par une attention à
tous les territoires avec lesquels nous
avons passé tous des contrats pour
pouvoir le ramener des financements sur
leurs projets structurant leur projet
qui leur am des services pour leurs
habitants je parlais en parler tout à
l'heure des maisons de santé
je reviens à ma question initiale
c'est en multipliant les services quand
tout à l'heure je vous ai montré par les
mois d'amour voilà un village qui était
complètement atome et là qui est en
train de revivre où il y a toute une
animation des liens sociaux qui en sont
en train de se retrouver autour de ce
commerce qui structure la vie du village
parce que à partir de la boulangerie
c'est d'autres services qui se mettent
en place il faut que l'on pousse la mise
en place de ces services alors après la
fibre c'est indispensable et la région
aujourd'hui elle ne fait que accompagner
les départements puisque c'est les
départements qui ont la responsabilité
d'amener la fibre elle les accompagne
mais là où on voit que la fibre
n'arrivera pas avant 2 ans ou trois ans
nous avons mis en place un système qui
amène le très haut débit
par voie hertzienne par voie radio ça
s'appelle Hercule et ça marche dans les
campagnes parce que dans les campagnes
quand la fibre sera partout quand le
très haut débit sera partout et bien
elles pourront relever la tête dignement
on fait tourner la parole Julien ou
double comment on aime donc en campagne
et comment lutte contre ce sentiment
d'abandon déjà faire le bilan le bilan
de la candidate sortant la candidate
sortante a été la présidente de la
région de Dijon de la métropole de Dijon
elle n'a pas été la présidente de la
Bourgogne Franche-Comté et certainement
pas la prison de la ruralité on a une
région essentiellement rurale tout a été
centralisé à Dijon les subventions les
emplois les développements les
attentions clairement il faut
rééquilibrer et je serai le président du
rééquilibrage territorial par une mesure
simple et concrète le bouclier rural à
chaque fois que la région versera un
euro d'argent public pour les métropoles
elle versera en retour un euro pour les
petites communes pour réaménager pour
investir pour favoriser la
réimplantation de commerce locaux la
réalité c'est que la politique de la
gauche l’extrême gauche c'est
effectivement une politique de Bobo
c'est un triptyque extrêmement funeste
plus d'impôts pour la ruralité pour les
automobilistes déjà et les
automobilistes francontois qui l'ont
payé durement c'est plus d'éoliennes
plus d'éoliennes qui plombe
l'attractivité qui dévastent nos
paysages qui saccagent la biodiversité
parce que Madame du fait à Beaujeu à la
fois elle développe l'éolien et en même
temps elle soutient les chauves-souris
qui sont massacrés par les éoliennes à
un moment donné il faut choisir moi ce
sera le choix de la nature des terroirs
des paysages et puis la politique des
vers de la gauche l'extrême gauche c'est
aussi disséminer les migrants dans nos
campagnes c'est le fameux vivre ensemble
sauf que dans la ruralité nous on veut
pas de migrants on veut des services
publics on veut du réseau on veut du
numérique on veut des médecins on veut
de la sécurité
merci beaucoup effectivement jérémy a un
point clé du développement du territoire
c'est l'agriculture on a rencontré vous
allez l'entendre à un agriculteur bio
qui manifestait hier avec ses collègues
à Lons-le-Saunier dans le Jura pour
davantage de reconnaissance et du coup
il vous interpelleront
Frédéric Jacquelin paysan boulanger à
Bersaillin dans le Jura je suis
également président du Groupement
d'agriculteurs bio du Jura
on est dans un contexte de
négociation de la politique agricole
commune qui nous est largement
défavorable depuis la loi nôtre les
régions ont une grande de grande
prérogative sur l'agriculture donc nous
souhaitons savoir ce que les candidats
comment les candidats vont soutenir
l'agriculture biologique et la
relocalisation de notre alimentation
Gilles plâtré le développement de notre
agriculture passe-t-il forcément par le
bio non non il passe notamment par le
bio mais le bio reste une filière de
niche si vous étendez le bleu
généralement vous n'arriverez pas à
tirer le revenu nécessaire de cette
filière là donc je le dis très
clairement ne croyez pas que l'avenir ça
soit tout au en bio en revanche il faut
effectivement aider ceux qui décident
j'étais dans la dernière ferme de
Montbéliard il y a quelques jours qui
s'est reconverti en bio il y a quelques
années et qui s'emportent bien donc on a
un choix à faire et ce choix c'est
vraiment celui de soutenir cette
agriculture j'ajouterai la sylviculture
et également la viticulture qui commence
à souffrir beaucoup du changement clim
parce que nous sommes une région où le
secteur primaire ces métiers est
beaucoup sont beaucoup plus importants
que dans le reste de la France la
population active qui vit de
l'agriculture est plus importante chez
nous ça veut dire quoi demain ça veut
dire créer d'abord un parlement de
l'agriculture en Bourgogne Franche-Comté
moi je tiens à ce que les acteurs de
l'agriculture de la civiculture la
viticulture se retrouve au moins deux
fois lent au conseil régional dans
toutes leurs filières pour qu'on puisse
discuter avec eux de la politique amener
ça veut dire créer un outil de promotion
je vais je vais vite un outil de
promotion c'est à dire un salon de
l'agriculture et de la viticulture de
Bourgogne et Franche-Comté et ça veut
dire aussi mettre les moyens de
communication parce qu'on en a marre de
la grippe à Chine c'est toujours le même
problème c'est
urbain qui viennent dire aux paysans
comment ils doivent vivre donc demain la
structuration des filières pour dégager
du revenu des aides européennes y
compris des aides hors pack elles n'ont
pas été sollicitées on a été nul sur la
mobilisation des crédits européens or il
y a de l'argent pour la y compris en
dehors des crédits de l'impact Denis
Thuriot est-ce qu'on favorise c'est ce
qu'on développe l'agriculture biologique
on pourra pas tout faire avec
l'agriculture biologique je m'en suis
exprime qui tout à l'heure par contre
trop d'agriculteurs n'arrivent pas à
vivre de leur métier donc il faut qu'on
soit antifas life effectivement les
régions gèrent maintenant la pacte
hormis les zones sur faciales et donc
nous devons être attentifs à aider les
bonnes filières à aussi assurer une
continuité dans la dans la consommation
dans les commandes et aujourd'hui à la
crise à la sortie de crise sanitaire la
proximité aussi de nos agriculteurs on
l'a retrouvé dans nos dans leurs clients
et c'est très bien ainsi mais moi je
voudrais vous faire une révélation parce
que la difficulté de l'accord de Madame
du fait avec les Verts elle va poser
souci elle va poser beaucoup de
contraintes à toute l'entreprise en
général et notamment au monde agricole
et un membre de LV m'a confié que cet
accord il est insatisfaisant il est même
il a même été choisi entre la peste et
le choléra ça veut dire que demain
madame Duffé qui s'est constitué
prisonnière du Parti communiste et des
vers radicaux sera coincé n'aura pas de
majorité et ce sont les qui vont imposer
de nouvelles normes aux agriculteurs de
façon excessive c'est ça la réalité
plus d'aide sur l'aéroport de Dole
Tavaux dans l'accord du fait remise en
cause la filière nucléaire c'est 500
emplois minimum dans le Territoire de
Belfort et ailleurs si je peux dans
l'accordéon
se désolidarisent de la majorité c'est
pas la même chose les verts avec Madame
Dufay ça sera beaucoup de contraintes
pour nos agriculteurs alors que nous
dans notre programme nous voulons les
aider à s'installer et c'est pas en leur
imposant des normes excessives la
transition écologique oui la transition
écologique destructrice d'emploi et
d'activités
les vers n'ont pas remis en cause les
différentes mesures que j'ai mises en
avant pour l'agriculture donc vous avez
posé tout à l'heure la question de la
bio la bio il faut la soutenir c'est une
agriculture vertueuse et aujourd'hui il
y a des arbitrages qui sont en train de
se faire au niveau national à l'aube de
la Pâques et qui ne leur sont pas
favorables j'ai d'ailleurs signé une
tribune en ce sens-là il n'y a pas
longtemps il faut qu'on soit très très
vigilant donc je défends la filière bio
mais tout le monde ne peut pas être en
bio aujourd'hui les bio il s'en sortent
parce que ils avaient un système qui est
en train d'être remis en cause à travers
la Pâque donc il faut être très vigilant
et ceux qui ne sont pas en bio et bien
notre notre responsabilité à la région
c'est de tout faire pour que ils aient
un revenu décent de leur travail alors
quand ils vendent leur bête par exemple
puisque nous sommes une grande région
d'élevage à l'extérieur la région elle
ne peut rien faire sur les cours des
marchés qui ne font que baisser se
dégrader par contre par contre
aussi et j'ai rencontré des éleveurs
dernièrement sur la prolifération des
grands prédateurs les Verts ont le sait
veulent la cohabitation entre nos
éleveurs et le loup c'est une
cohabitation impossible moi je serai
clairement pour que la région prenne une
position pour qu'il n'y ait plus de
grands prédateurs dans nos campagnes en
Bourgogne Franche-Comté car la
cohabitation est impossible il faut
soutenir nos éleveurs et non pas des
grands prédateurs merci Julien Odoul il
nous reste moins de 5 minutes
d'émissions une dernière question en
guise de conclusion je me tourne vers
vous Gilles plâtré vous avez 50 secondes
pourquoi faut-il voter pour vos dimanche
prochain je m'adresse à celles et ceux
qui aiment la Bourgogne et la
Franche-Comté ce sont deux régions qui
ont gardé l'identité même dans le cadre
élargi nous pouvons ensemble les faire
rayonner en respectant leur identité en
retournant sur le terrain pour défendre
la sécurité de nos concitoyens qui
deviendra une compétence régionale à
part entière en mettant la santé comme
un objectif pour lequel nous lutterons
contre la désertification médicale et
pour l'adaptation du logement de nos
aînés à la perte d'autonomie
pouvons faire en sorte que l'écologie ne
soit plus un problème gauchiste mais une
réalité de terrain qui sera défendue
contre les éoliennes pour le nucléaire
pour les petites unités de méthanisation
raisonnées bref une écologie de terrain
loin de la petite politique politicienne
c'est cette région que nous voulons vous
avez le choix il y a 4 figures 4 projets
ne vous trompez pas votez mais votez par
amour pour ces territoires que nous
aimons par-dessus tout merci Gilles
plâtré Marigny du fait votre conclusion
s'il vous plaît la liste que je conduis
a mis en son centre trois priorités tout
faire pour l'emploi la protection de
l'emploi le développement de l'emploi
accélérer tout ce qui relève de la
transition écologique énergétique et
puis travailler en s'appuyant sur la
troisième devise de notre République la
fraternité voilà pourquoi je vous invite
à voter pour cette liste et je vous le
dis une liste de gauche elle met les
solidarités en son centre et bien nous
veillerons à ce que demain il y ait des
politiques différenciées territoires par
territoire selon les difficultés que
rencontre ces territoires et je pense
bien sûr à Saint-Claude nous mettrons en
place des géographies de territoire de
reconquête pour véritablement faire
vivre une solidarité régionale merci
beaucoup Marie guide Dufay Julien Oudoul
pourquoi faut-il voter pour vous
dimanche prochain vous avez 50 secondes
je m'adresse aux électeurs du
rassemblement national à toutes celles
et tous ceux qui ont déjà voté pour
Marine Le Pen dimanche allez voter
dimanche faites-nous gagner dimanche
faites gagner vos idées vos valeurs vous
pouvez faire barrage à la gauche à
l'extrême gauche j'appelle les électeurs
les républicains à me rejoindre à faire
barrage au folles politiques des
extrémistes verts à faire barrage à ce
funeste triptyque plus d'impôts plus
d'éoliennes plus de migrants ensemble
nous pouvons gagner j'ai besoin de vous
la Bourgogne Franche-Comté a besoin de
VOUS dimanche voter
merci Julien Oudoul et enfin Denis
thuriaux votre conclusion vous avez
comme chacun des trois autres candidats
50 secondes l'abstention ne doit pas
devenir le premier parti de Bourgogne
Franche-Comté l'abstention n'a pas de
visage l'abstention n'a pas de programme
l'abstention ne vous aidera pas un
million 300000 personnes parmi vous ne
sont pas allés voter dimanche dernier
donc contrairement à ce qui a été dit
tout reste possible parce qu'il n'y a
jamais eu une telle abstention en France
ce choix il se limite à la gauche qui
s'étalit avec l'extrême gauche bloquante
qui va créer la suppression beaucoup
d'emplois ce choix est se limite avec un
programme commun d'ailleurs ce qui n'est
pas contesté entre LR debout la France
et le rassemblement national ce ne sont
pas les gens de droite constructives ce
ne sont pas les gens de droite gaulliste
alors moi ce que je vous invite à faire
c'est choisir la raison c'est choisir
l'équilibre c'est choisir un programme
de relance et donc la famille que je
représente c'est tout les bourguignon
franc-comtois c'est pas juste l'extrême
gauche de Marie guide Dufay moi je dis
simplement à nos électeurs vous avez le
pouvoir le pouvoir de voter utiliser le
dimanche merci beaucoup Denis tourio
merci à tous les quatre d'être venu
débattre sur ce plateau ici au Palais
des Congrès de Beaune on vous souhaite
une très bonne dernière journée de
campagne de main vous donne rendez-vous
sur notre plateau à tous les quatre
dimanche puisque ce sera la grande
soirée électorale à partir de 19h55
pour les prochaines années le conseil
régional de Bourgogne Franche-Comté
merci un petit peu après 20h du matin
dès 20h je vous promets si c'est pas
trop serré dès 20h merci Jérémy merci
Stéphane d'être venu et merci à vous de
votre fidélité tout de suite vos
journaux en Bourgogne et en
Franche-Comté passer une très belle
soirée et vive la politique
[Musique]